Me gustaría empezar esta canción que escribí
sobre el ansia incesante y el eterno deseo
con un poema de paradojas petrarquianas
de Sir Thomas Wyatt el Viejo:
"No tengo paz, y ya terminó mi guerra;
Tengo miedo y esperanza; ardo y me congelo como el hielo;
Vuelo con el viento,
y aún así no puedo elevarme;
Y nada tengo,
Y todo lo abarco".
Quiero lo que no puedo tener, necesito lo que no puedo desear
Quiero tener lo que no tengo, lo que quiero.
Tener lo que no tengo, lo que quiero.
Quiero lo que no puedo tener, necesito lo que no puedo desear
Tener lo que no tengo, lo que quiero
Tener pero no tengo.
Parece como si todo lo que tenía fuera una pérdida en mi dolorida espalda
Como si se hubiera ido con el último tren, cariño no te preocupes
Toda nube guarda un resquicio de esperanza
Solo un poco de lluvia, un poco de lluvia, un poco de lluvia
Quiero lo que no puedo tener, necesito lo que no puedo desear
Tener lo que no tengo, lo que quiero
Lo que no puedo tener, necesito lo que no puedo desear
Tener lo que no tengo
Mi cabeza no parará, y corazón me dice que siga
Nadie sabe cómo sujetarme
Mi cabeza no parará, y corazón me dice...
Las cosas buenas son para quienes saben esperar
Y yo no puedo quedarme quieta
No puedo esperar en la cola para siempre
Estar parada en el aire frío
Poniendo buena cara
Harta del "después, quizás"
Tómalo, fíngelo, cógelo, tómalo o déjalo vida
Y tengo que decirte
Que tengo que nombrarlo
Tengo que ver, así que por favor, oh por favor
Por favor, dame la razón, porque™
Mi cabeza no parará
Y mi corazón dice que continúe
Nadie sabe cómo sostenerme
My cabeza no parará y me corazón dice: "ve a por ello".
Las cosas buenas tiene que estar aquí, sí, justo aquí
Aquí, justo aquí, justo aquí
No voy a vivir eternamente
Solo tengo una oportunidad
Harta de escuchar "más tarde, quizás"
Cógelo, fíngelo, hazlo, déjalo vida
Y tengo que nombrarlo, tengo ya que reclamarlo
Tengo que adueñarme de ello
Oh por favor, por favor, dime que sí
Quiero lo que no puedo tener, necesito lo que no puedo desear
Quiero tener lo que no puedo tener, lo que quiero
Tener lo que no tengo, ya lo sabes
Mi cabeza no parará, y me corazón me dice que siga
Nadie sabe cómo sostenerme, no
Mi cabeza no paraá, y me corazón me dice que siga
Porque quiero lo que no puedo tener, necesito lo que no puedo desear
Tener lo que... tener lo que quiero
Lo que no puedo tener, necesito lo que no puedo desear
Tener lo que no tengo, lo que quiero
(Aplausos.)